there has become a thing that's gone on  it seems like in this especially this  last year where ideology is more  important than art way more certainly to  the awards yeah and it's just you know  it it's like you know ideology trumps  art ideology Trump's individual effort  ideology Trump's good ideology Trump's  entertaining I have always really  appreciated the way you pushed back when  anyone tried to stifle you shut you up  shame you bully you they tried it with  the last one with Once Upon a Time in  the Hollywood some [ __ ] about Margot  Robbie doesn't have enough lines and you  do what I wish other people would do  instead of apologizing like a little  [ __ ] you say I don't agree with your  assessment yeah yeah if somebody brings  up something that actually is legitimate  I'll even have a conversation with them  about it because I'm actually into  interesting thought and I don't have to  even agree with you oh but that's  point right that's an interesting point